good afternoon everybody
a couple of things at the top
today's announcement by micron is
another big win
for america micron is investing 15
billion dollars over the next decade at
a manufacturing facility in idaho and
they directly credit the passage of
the chips act that made this possible
just this week we've seen first solar
toyota honda and corning make major
announcements of new investments and new
jobs as a direct result of the
president's economic plan
u.s manufacturing is back
americans have experienced an
unacceptable level of flight of flight
delays and cancellations this year due
to airline issues
when these disruptions occur it's really
difficult to figure out if you will
receive a meal voucher and hotel
accommodations so two weeks ago
secretary buda judge told the top u.s
airlines that our administration planned
to publish an interactive airline
customer service dashboard before labor
day to give americans
more transparency about what airlines
owe them
when there is a delay or cancellation
due to staffing or mechanical problems
secretary booty judge also urged the
airlines to immediately improve their
customer service plans before the
dashboard launch today the department of
transportation officially launched the
dashboard and were proud to report that
airlines vastly improved their plans
we have a
graphic right behind me we love graphics
here as you know
before the secretary's letter there were
significantly more red x's across this
table
none of the airlines had guaranteed that
they would cover meals or hotels when
they are at fault now eight of the top
airlines cover hotels and nine of them
cover meals before secretary boudija's
letter only one airline guaranteed they
would rebook you at no cost now nine out
of the ten do
so
this is a huge win for american
travelers from the start of this
administration president biden has
directed his team to work with airlines
to help americans get where they need to
go safely affordably and reliably
and we will not hesitate to hold the
airlines accountable if airlines aren't
providing you with these services
file a complaint with the department of
transportation our administration has
your back
lastly i want to make a few comments on
the un high commissioner for human
rights report on xinjiang that was
released just last night the united
states welcomes this report this
important report which describes
authoritariatively the abhorrent human
rights treatment of the uyghur and and
other minority communities by the
people's republic of china government
the report deepens our grave concern
regarding the ongoing genocide and
crimes against humanity that china is
perpetrating
our position on the atrocities in
xinjiang has been clearly demonstrated
with our words and in our actions the
biden administration has taken concrete
measures including improving visa
restrictions
global magnitsky act and other financial
sanctions export controls import
restrictions and the president has
rallied
allies and partners including the g7
commitment to ensure all global global
supply chains are free from the use of
forced labor including from xinjiang
we will continue to work closely with
partners and the international community
to hold china accountable and we will
call on china to immediately cease
committing these atrocities release
those unjustly detained account for
those disappeared and allow independent
investigators full and unhindered access
to xinjiang
tibet
and across china with that
all right go ahead zeke what do you got
thanks durian can you confirm that the
united states is ending uh humanitarian
parole for afghan refugees and is the
administration concerned that this is
going to make it more difficult for
people trying to flee the taliban's rule
to get
safety
so um
here's we have
an update on on the enduring freedom the
the operation allies welcome uh what it
looks like long term this is a this is
uh
this is an update that uh the department
uh that the that the department of
defense announced recently
and so look our commitment to our afghan
allies is endearing
we have welcomed nearly 90 000 afghans
to our country over the past year and
have been providing relocation
assistance over the past year as well as
part of our efforts to continue to
welcome our afghan allies we are
adopting a new model where afghans
arrivals will travel directly to the
communities where they will be moving
with the help of refugee resettlement
organizations without a safe haven
stopover in the united states we have
also been
pivoting toward welcoming afghans from
visa programs that have long term
durable status such as the afghan
special
immigrant visa the civ program si siv
programs as you hear us call it and
refugee admissions programs so that
afghans who are looking to resettle in
the united states will remain with an
immigration status that provides a path
to long-term permanent residence rather
than a temporary status which is what is
provided through humanitarian parole at
the same time we have been undertaking
substantial effort to improve our
relocation efforts
working to make them more efficient we
are developing a system to help
americans with family members in
afghanistan as well as afghans who have
arrived in the u.s over the past year
bring their family members to the to the
united states so we're going to continue
to improve uh the siv pro process and
have substantially increased the number
of staff processing
siv application by by more than 15
15-fold since the beginning of the
buying administration so this is
important to us this has been a priority
and that's how we're going to make this
uh process work a little bit better so
the question though of the is the
administrative concern that this process
by by pushing people to that longer term
residency visa program then that's going
to make it more difficult for people who
are just trying to get out to get out
the purpose of the parole is to allow
people to get the united states get to
safety
so we look we know that many uh many of
our allies and afghans uh remain in
afghanistan remain under threatened in
the country so we are putting the
infrastructure in place overseas to
increase
the pace of our relocations and we have
made a number
of process improvements to refugee and
siv immigration process that should make
this faster so we believe it's going to
make this faster we believe this is an
improvement in the in the process and
this is a commitment that we continue to
have i think you've had an update on the
situation in in jackson right now the
federal support of what a steam have
been able to get to the city thus far
and has the president spoken to the
governor yet and what's been the reason
for the delay so fema just to give you a
little bit of an update on what's been
going on in the ground and from the
federal government the fema
administrator deanne criswell will
travel to jackson mississippi tomorrow
to assess the ongoing emergency response
as you know the president took immediate
action to improve
to approve the governor's emergency
declaration request and directed his
team to surge assistance to mississippi
as soon as he uh got
got the declaration request the
president and vice president bolt spoke
with the mayor of jackson yesterday we
read out that from the president that
they spoke and fema administrators spoke
with the governor earlier in the week so
fema has a number of personnel on site
in the state in the state emergency
operations center and is coordinating
with the mississippi emergency
management team to ensure that everyone
has access to water the epa also has a
subject matter expert on the ground to
support the emergency assessment of the
jackson water treatment
plants the agency is also working to
expedite delivery of equipment needed to
repair jackson's water treatment plant
so we are doing everything that we can
to make sure that we're helping the
people of mississippi
again we are in close touch
we have had multiple conversations with
the governor and clearly we we read out
the our conversation with the mayor and
uh we'll continue to have those open
lines and lastly for me uh you mentioned
the uh the u.n report on uh china chains
genocide in xinjiang what the
administration is planning a phone call
between the president president xi uh
sorry meeting between the uh
president-elect president g in the
coming weeks or months
why is now the time after support the
time for for a meeting between these two
years to take place given chinese
atrocities wait say that one more time
you're saying why shouldn't we have this
meeting
you're planning a meeting right now why
are you do you plan to go forward with
that
i don't have anything to read out about
a upcoming meeting or
or anything like that any specifics of a
meeting that the president could
potentially have uh president xi i just
don't have anything to share but there's
been no change to the the plan actually
they spoke on the phone a couple of
weeks ago that they were planning to
meet in person that's that's process
there's just nothing for me there's not
a process that i can speak or share with
you at this time
thanks you guys have talked about the
president's speech tonight as one that's
about the continued battle for the soul
of the nation uh republican house leader
kevin mccarthy said this morning that
the president does not understand the
soul of america since we're a year and a
half into this present city and the
country is still so divided could
mccarthy have a point
so let me say a few things uh about um
the response to to
kevin mccarthy and it comes from himself
like what he said
uh on january 6
after january 6 2021 one week after uh
after the january six insurrection i'm
sorry january 13th
and you know he said the violence
destruction and chaos we saw earlier was
unacceptable he said this on january
13th of 2021 it was undemocratic it was
un-american we all should stand united
in condemning the mob together and then
he said
so he and then he said the president
bears responsibility for wednesday's
attack on congress by mobs rioters this
is speaking about the former president
the president strongly agrees with kevin
mccarthy on the january 6th at comments
in the january 13th 2021 comments and
does not find the comments that that
kevin mccarthy made then to be divisive
in the least but rather
aligning with fundamental nonpartisan
mainstream american values that we
uphold the rule of law reject political
violence and condemn violence against
law enforcement and that's what we're
talking about when we're talking about
protecting our democracy when we're
talking about fighting our democracy
that was those were the words of kevin
mccarthy and the president agreed with
that kevin mccarthy he agreed with the
kevin mccarthy of january 6 he agreed
with the kevin mccarthy of january 13 of
2021
and what we hear from him
what we hear from him of course is a
change of heart uh and even formally
punished fellow republicans like liz
cheney who've had the courage to
consistently tell the truth about the
attack
on the rule of law and the law
enforcement that day and continuing to
the threat to democracy that these
extreme conspiracy
theories represent that is what we're
talking about and as far as what the
president is going to say tonight we've
talked about this
when he talks about the soul
of the nation uh this is uh
this is not a topic that is new to him
if you follow him if you follow them
throughout this administration also uh
through the campaign this is a topic
that he has talked about
for some time since 2017 and the speech
just to give you a little bit about what
the speech is going to be about it's
going to be optimistic he will speak
about how he believes we can get through
this current moment this critical moment
that we are we are currently in he
believes this is a moment where a lot is
at stake you'll hear him talk about the
core values of what is at the stake in
this moment and how he we and how he is
going to continue to protect uh for
protect equality and democracy he will
also talk about in a very direct way
about what he sees as a threat at this
moment in this in time basically what
kevin mccarthy said on january 6 2021
what kevin mccarthy said on january 13
2021 the threat of our democracy that
insurrection that mob that we saw come
uh come down on the capitol
just too quick on that though
you're talking about kevin mccarthy from
from that day we've obviously seen like
you said a pretty big change of heart
from from uh leader mccarthy you know
who has since really distanced
themselves and from any investigation
into january six really stood lockstep
with the former president so i guess i'm
asking about what's the president's
relationship and thoughts about kevin
mccartney today does he can does he have
a relationship with him i mean he could
very easily become the next speaker of
the house does he talk to him does does
he view kevin mccarthy as one of these
republicans
here's what i'm going to say i'm you
know i've already laid out what i
thought what we think about uh about
about kevin mccarthy we're not going to
go into any more specifics on that this
is what what we're talking about tonight
is what the president's going to deliver
to the american people and and
why it is important for what he sees
it's important to have uh this
conference conversation why it is so
important uh for to talk about what is
at stake at this moment uh you know when
you ask me about the mega agenda
especially as it relates to congress as
it relates to elected officials
it is one of the most extreme agendas
that we have seen
and it is a a part of the uh
it is the extreme part of the republican
party and we're talking about they want
nationwide ban on abortions they want to
give tax cut to billionaires and
corporations while raising taxes on
middle-class americans they are
threatening political violence
and they are attacking our democracy and
so the president is going to take this
time to talk to the american people who
majority agree with him on
and talk about you know how can we
continue
to fight for our democracy and do it in
an optimistic way take that moment uh to
uh to give a people hope because this
president believes uh that we can turn
this around
uh thanks parade
is tonight a political speech no it's
not a political speech this is an
opportunity again for the president uh
to directly have a conversation uh with
the with the uh the american people um
look he's gonna talk about of course
he'll talk about the importance of
engagement he'll talk about voter voter
participation but this is a speech about
such a broader subject
you know what it means to be a democracy
and what it means to participate
in our in our democracy given where we
are as a nation and he believes the
stakes are very high and that is
important to go out and articulate what
those stakes are
and why it's important for people to
participate in their democracy and at
the end of the day why it is worth
fighting for and that is what he's going
to talk about tonight that's what you're
going to hear from him and again it's a
broader subject about this moment that
we're in currently i'm impressed and the
people on the left are pretty happy
about the more aggressive tone they're
seeing from the president and the white
house but you're also facing some
criticism which has been brought up that
this aggressive tone
is also stoking the divisiveness that
he's trying to heal
any concerns about that you know the
president's never gonna shy away from
calling out what he sees and i said this
yesterday and i and i'll say this now
uh you know
i'm assuming the divisive tone is coming
from from
from whom from the right from the right
so
look we understand we hit a nerve we get
that we understand that they're trying
to hide and uh we understand that ultra
maga office holders want to play games
here and dodge accountability for their
extreme proposals and actions but
they're just telling on themselves look
the president has always always squarely
targeted his his criticism on elected
leaders this is about what they're doing
in congress those extreme
mega republicans
those who who are who hold office
the first time that the president said
ultra mega was about rick scott's
radical plan
to raise taxes on millions of middle
class americans and put medicare on the
chopping box post social security on the
talking block i just mentioned national
abortions that banned that that these uh
mega republicans want to do it is
important to call that out and let's not
forget when you think about medicare
when you think about social security
those are popular things
when you think about roe and protecting
women's right to choose those are
majority of americans support that so
how so that's what we're talking about
here we're talking about
agenda that is not popular we're talking
about agendas that is incredibly extreme
we're talking about an agenda that is
not in line where a majority of
americans are so yeah the president's
going to talk about that he's not going
to shy away but again this is going to
be about a speech that will be
optimistic that we'll talk about
participating in our democracy and how
important it is to do that and how
important it is to continue to fight
just one quick question does the white
house have any intelligence or
reaction to the death of the chairman of
luke oil
the second largest oil producer in
russia he'd been a criticism apparently
died after falling out of hospital
window and was a critic of the war in
ukraine uh
i don't have a comment on that we're
certainly not going to get into any
speculation on um on how he died
okay
go back to jackson yesterday you
detailed the myriad of the federal
funding sources uh that could be used to
address what we're dealing with right
now are there any concerns however about
the difference between allocation and
the money actually arriving in certain
places about the process for jackson to
access that funding once the federal
government is allocated and perhaps the
state is keeping the contract with the
grant application so you talk about the
bipartisan infrastructure law and the
american rescue plan so we we have put
real emphasis on making it easier for
state and local
governments to access the federal
funding that is something that's been
important in this administration to do
that's one reason we asked every state
to appoint a state infrastructure
coordinator to help streamline
communications and information flow and
the white house infrastructure
information team has also been engaging
directly with state and local
governments and tribal governments to
help them quickly access the necessary
technical assistance and capacity to
underserved communities
in particular so we have also partnered
with non-profit organizations to assist
communities in assessing and deploying
federal infrastructure funding including
bloomberg philanthropies
emerson collective ford foundation
and others and so so much more our goal
is to help against state local tribal
territorial governments navigate
access and deploy infrastructure
resources that will build a better
america this is why the president fought
so hard uh to get this bipartisan
infrastructure law a law that is
historical and will make and will change
uh and will change the lives of so many
americans because of
what you guys have done that jackson has
had the access or the ability to tap
into the funds you've allocated
uh to the degree they need in this
moment so again we're
our goal is to make it as easy as we can
for state and local governments to
access those funds
we're going to we have an inflammation
implement implementation team as i just
uh spoke about and we're going to
continue to work with state and local
governments there's also not for profits
on the ground and other organizations
that we will work through and our hope
is to
make sure that the people of jackson
have what they need and again we've been
in constant communication these past
couple of days
with the mayor of jackson with local
officials
the director fema griswold is going will
be there tomorrow so as you have seen us
in in times like these when there is a
catastrophe sadly in these states
we have uh the federal government has
acted quickly uh in in order to help the
people in in that in that community in
that state and then one more movement
just uh with job state coming up uh
may sound a little bit paradoxical but
stick with me here given the robust kind
of aggressiveness of the fed chair in
jacksonville is there any concern that
perhaps
uh a better than expected jobs report
will create an economic response from
the fed that drives something the white
house does not want so as you know phil
we don't comment on
the what
what the fed is going to do
part of our fighting inflation the plan
that the president has put forth is to
give them their independence uh to make
the monetary decision
to deal with inflation that we see
across the country and
again we believe like they have the best
monetary
plans policies to make that happen as it
relates to the jobs the jobs report i
spoke about this a couple times already
look you know i don't want to get ahead
of the numbers uh tomorrow we have been
very clear that we see
that the economy is in transition after
a
a historic economic growth that we saw
last year and we believe that we can
continue those gains but again we're in
a transition uh into a more stable and
steady a steady growth we won't see we
believe we won't see those the 600 000
numbers that we have seen for some time
and and that that number is going to be
it's going to cool a little bit you've
heard us say that
and so that's our anticipation which we
think
is where the economy uh is going but
again we have a strong labor market
which is important consumer spending uh
is uh is up we see business investing
all of those things
are critically and important um and so
we're gonna look at all the economic
data but certainly not i'm not gonna get
ahead of the jobs numbers for tomorrow
thank you i want to circle back to the
afghan
refugees so just is any is there
anything being done
for afghan allies who or those
who have sought to come to the united
states who already filed for parole and
are currently waiting in the backlog of
applications and to be clear are there
only options now as well as anybody
trying to flee afghanistan and come to
the u.s either siv or the refugee
program and i would follow oh sure and
as you know there's a there's the act uh
that is in congress that we have been
really working uh that the
administration continues to support the
passage of the afghan adjustment act to
provide afghans who have come to the u.s
through operations allies welcome which
is what i talked through a second ago
and a pathway to durable immigration
status so there is that
pathway as well that we're going to
continue to work with
congress on um so
i'm sorry but that they would need an
approved application absolutely i just
wanted to make i just wanted to make
sure that i
stated that as well look as of august
9th just to give you some numbers here
over 17 000 individuals have submitted
all documents required to apply for
chief of mission review
or are beyond the chief of mission stage
we are working to process those as
quickly as possible and welcome them
into the united states so we're this is
something that we're working on uh
pretty regularly this is important uh to
the department of state and so the
afghan si program remains active uh and
the state con continues to receive and
process new siv applications as
expeditiously as possible as part of our
efforts to improve the program we have
cut the average
com review time to six of what it was
under the previous administration from
510 days in june 2020 to 82 days in june
2022. i don't have the specific numbers
as you were asking about the backlogs
but we are quickly trying to move that
forward to move that through uh and
again you know we have welcomed nearly
90 000 afghans into the country thus far
just referenced though as the siv yes it
is it is so but my question is for those
who have filed an application for parole
i'm so sorry yes
i hear what you're saying will they
still have a chance to get parole or are
they basically should they ditch
that just forget about the fact that
they're in that pipeline and try to
refer that's a very good question i
would refer you to the department of
state on the on the parolees and the and
where the ones who were kind of in that
in that process and where they are going
to ultimately be and what their what
their uh options are i don't have that
specific with me the two programs you
referenced both still have years-long
backlogs even with the
movements that you were just describing
to increase staff
does my administration think that at
this point for somebody who's trying to
flee afghanistan and they're pursuing
either siv or the refugee program that
there's actually a realistic chance that
they could make it through the pipeline
within i mean the end of this
presidential world we're gonna do
everything that we can uh to make sure
that uh we take care of um the families
the american families uh that are still
in
afghanistan and also
our friends and allies in afghanistan as
well so we're going to do everything
that we can to make it happen
i know department of state has been on
top of this they have been working
through this
you know for some time now and so this
is a priority of ours for sure thank you
thanks if you can go back to uh
tonight's speech she said the president
is going to speak in a direct way about
what he sees as a threat does that
include former president trump will he
mention the former president by name or
any republican so look i've said this
before the president's never going to
shy away from talking about his
predecessor he hasn't
i'm about to answer your question so
give me a second but it's not a speech
about the former president
or about a single politician or about a
political party it's about the american
democracy which is what i've been trying
to lay out here this is so much broader
so much bigger
than any one party than any one person
and it's an optimistic speech again
about where we are as a nation and where
we can go
and it's about the fundamental struggle
around the globe between autocracy and
democracy and how democracy is a
critical foundation for this country
to move forward and about what we can do
can be done right now to beat back the
forces that are threatening that are
threatening us and so he's been working
on this for a while he's been thinking
about the speech for a while he's talked
about uh soul of the nation the first
time you've heard him do that was when
he wrote wrote an op-ed in the atlantic
back in august of 2017. so this is
nothing new to him he feels it is his
responsibility to bring the to bring
american people to
together and to answer a fundamental
question about what kind of nation we
are going to be and that's what you're
going to hear from the president tonight
again he's been thinking about this for
some time
this is not a new subject or topic for
him but i thought it was things that you
were saying to my colleagues questions
you know concern about this maga
republican this extremist agenda and
that's something he's going to talk
about tonight how is that not a
political well i said he's not going to
shy away from that
and of course he's going to talk about
voter participation of course he's going
to talk about um
getting americans to
get involved and participate in this
effort to fight our democracy that is
something that he is certainly going to
talk about but what what i'm trying to
say is this is a broader speech and
you'll hear from him directly
this is not about
one political party it is not what about
one political one person
in politics this is about what we are
going to do as a country uh
to uh to continue to fight for our
democracy again something that he has
talked about for some time and uh and
that's what you're going to hear from
him if you followed him through the
campaign if you followed him through the
administration this is not new and he
will speak directly about that directly
about the current events
but again he's not going to shy away
from uh from from from the extremism
that we see today
but again this there's a broader
component of the speech and you'll hear
about that later this evening yeah
thanks green uh on this russian oil cap
the u.s is trying to get that in place
before
eu sanctions go into place in december
that would ban seaborne shipments
russian oil
if the oil cap fails what's the level of
concern inside the administration
that those eu
sanctions can drive up the price of oil
and reverse all the gains that you all
been touting for the past two months i
mean i'm not going to get into
hypotheticals from here they're going to
be meeting the g7 finance minister
ministers meeting is happening tomorrow
so they'll have that discussion look
this is um
this is
exactly what the president and g7
leaders have directed relevant members
of their team to explore as you know the
mechanism to set a global price tag
cap on uh for russia oil you know to
starve as you know putin of his main
source of cash and forcing down the
price of russian oil to help blunt the
impact of putin's war at the pump
they're going to meet tomorrow uh as i
said the the finance ministers the g7
finance ministers uh meeting and
and and we'll see what comes out of that
don't want to get ahead of that meeting
which is happening tomorrow would the
u.s consider lifting its ban on imports
of russian oil if the price is capped
i'm just not going to get ahead of a
meeting that's happening tomorrow
yeah thank you um given the ongoing
threats of political violence and
the majority of americans saying they're
concerned about american democracy and
something like 40 of americans saying
that they think civil war could happen
in the next 10 years
how is the president going to deliver an
optimistic speech how is he optimistic
in the facebook have you followed joe
biden have you listened to him make
speeches in the past before
this is a president
i would argue who knows how to do that
who knows how to deliver an optimistic
speech at the same time call out
what is happening in this moment and
that's what you're going to hear from
this president
you know
if you if you look listen to his past
speeches he has done that how do we
bring people together how do we get
people involved uh in this part in this
process in this participation in our
democracy
and look
just because you call out what you're
seeing in this current moment
the extremism the attack on our
democracy the attack on our freedom
the concerns that americans have
themselves doesn't mean you can't bring
the country together and show a positive
way forward show some hope give some
people some hope and you'll see that
from this president tonight
a completely unrelated uh also not a
thing to be optimistic about um
the the national assessment of
educational progress
uh is
has this new testing that shows that
nine-year-olds lost ground in both math
and reading in pretty dramatic ways as a
result of the pandemic um
what is the president going to do about
it what is the administration going to
do about this severe learning loss and
does the administration shoulder any
blame for not pushing schools to reopen
sooner
so let's step back to where we were
not too long ago when this president
walked into this administration
how mismanaged the pandemic the response
of the pandemic was
how 47
of schools
were
in in less than six months
our schools went from 40 46 percent uh
to to open to nearly all of them being
open to full-time that was the work of
this president and that was the work of
democrats in spite of republicans not
voting for the american rescue plan
which 130 billion dollars went to school
to have the ventilation to be able to uh
have the tutoring and and the teachers
and being able to hire more teachers and
that was because of the work that this
administration uh did we were we were in
a place where
again schools were not open uh the
economy was shut down businesses were
shut down and
what we have seen is uh you know we've
seen the numbers but i think that's what
we see that's how we saw it it shows you
how mismanaged uh the pandemic was uh
and how the impact of that mismanagement
had on the on on kids progress and
academic well-being and so again our
priority remains to make sure states and
schools and districts are using these
funds that 130 billion billion dollars
this is going to go again to tutoring to
more teachers real solutions real
solutions to make sure that our kids are
getting what they need and you know
every republican congress voted against
that money that is the reality we had to
do this on our own
and so uh you know we're going to make
sure that those funds are directed uh to
the most resources towards students who
are who will full who will uh who fell
the furthest behind which is important
and we must repair the damage that was
done by the last administration the
mismanagement that was done by the last
administration
but again this is
something that we take we took very
seriously which is why we passed the
american rescue plan which is why we put
in 130 billion dollars to deal with uh
what we were seeing in schools and so uh
you know we're going to continue to make
that uh to to do that work and work
closely with the schools
corrine um two questions
one on uh jackson
it is in a state where this water crisis
is one of the poorest states in the
south
with that said
it's compounding the water crisis
compounding so much negatively in that
community
and i remember during the bush years
during her hurricane katrina new orleans
was set aside
as a special case
as well as detroit
was set aside as a special case for them
to work on revitalization renaissance if
you will is jackson one of those places
that this administration would hold in
that kind of category because the
economy is definitely impacted poor
state etc people are not working right
now
it is unsanitary to go without water
this way
is jackson one of those spaces that
could have a a special designation
because of the compounding negatives and
now this
so
the bayan harris administration we're
committed to helping uh the people of
mississippi cope with this current
emergency and we are going to continue
to work with the state and local
government officials to explore i can
tell you all options
to ensure that the people of jackson
have the access to your point to clean
safe drinking water i don't have any
announcement to make i listed out
yesterday with the american rescue plan
and what that provided for water
upgrades which was 450 million dollars
20 million went to it went to jackson
has already gone to jackson to address
water and sewer instruction
infrastructure needs the state also has
about 75 million dollars in bipartisan
infrastructure law funding available to
provide clean and safe water and so
we'll continue to partner closely we're
going to look at all options i don't
have anything for you at this time to
announce and lastly i asked the same
question a week ago
tomorrow now there's expected to be a
civil rights meeting with the president
what can you read out about that
i'm not going to comment about about any
potential meeting expected meeting i'm
just not going to comment on that moment
where
the civil rights leaders and the
president have a lot to talk about
voting rights has gone i mean so many
different issues that impact a community
that's still underserved with some of
the highest numbers of negatives
in almost every category
so we have been
uh in con had continued conversation
with civil rights mem members and
leaders uh since the beginning of this
administration we value those
relationships
the president has met as you know with
uh civil rights leaders uh during as
president a few times and we take you
know we we um we respect uh
that that relationship we expect our
conversations that we have with them and
there's always a long list of things to
talk about
including voting rights and so many
other issues that affect different
communities i don't have anything more
to share i don't have an agenda to share
with you at this time
but that is a relationship that we have
held
as an important one not just during the
president's uh not just during this
administration
as president but during vice president
and also as senator
a couple of months ago the creole did a
story on the president's black agenda he
carries a card in his pocket and on that
he writes things and
at some point in time he had a list of
items with a black agenda what are some
of those black agenda issues today if
you were to go to him and ask him if
that's on his card
look
when it comes to um
if you look at the president's economic
plan
he's been very deliberate
i just talked about the american rescue
plan i talked about the bipartisan
infrastructure law and how that plan is
helping
the black community i laid out what it's
what we have
what we have put forth to help jackson
mississippi
but it's not just that we know about
education what he's done for hbcus more
than six billion dollars that he has put
forth a historic amount of money to help
hbcu so education has been really
important you think about the student
loan
a loan forgiveness that he put forward
last week that's going to help
communities at need right it's going to
help the folks that who are at the most
risk if you think about 90
of that plan is going to help people who
are making under 75 000
that is part of the president's plan if
you think about going back to the
bipartisan infrastructure law that's
going to
that's going to
create jobs for people 90
of what you see from that law is going
to uh
90 percent uh it's it's going to create
jobs where uh folks you know don't have
to have a high school college degree
that is going to be important we're
talking about building economic wealth
we're talking about having that
generational wealth that's so important
for brown brown and black communities
that they don't have that's what the
american rescue plan does when it helps
start small businesses for for folks to
start small businesses so they can
develop that uh generational wealth all
of those things are part of what the
president has worked on to make sure
that he's building the economy from the
bottom up and the middle out so he's
going to continue to do that work it
doesn't end there we just passed the
inflation reduction act that's going to
help many communities as well lowers
costs of prescription drugs when you
think about
communities of color how much our
seniors have to pay thousands of dollars
a month on prescription drugs so that
work continues uh it doesn't end uh it
doesn't end there
but
we would say that there's been so much
historic effort uh historic legislation
that's been done under this
administration
that's going to help many communities
including the black community i'll come
back down more on the soul of america
from the back
what do you think the president's
message tonight is for americans who
consider themselves republicans or may
still support the former president is
there something in the speech
directed to them
well
look the president really does believe
that this
that what he's going to talk about
um
is something that many americans are
going to care about it doesn't matter
which side of the aisle that you care
where that you sit at when you think
about the possibilities of our democracy
when you think about um how we are going
to fight for to protect our rights right
to protect our democracy he thinks
that's going to touch a lot of people
we have seen somebody just talked about
polling and how we see that many people
are concerned about where our democracy
is
i would argue that's probably across the
board
and when we talk about the extremism
we're talking about a very small
peace
component of
of the american public right we're
talking about a very small component of
of uh
mega republicans in congress
that
that is something that they believe
right but we know and the president
believes and is optimistic that there
are many many americans who want to
continue to make sure that we uphold our
democracy
and so that is something
that um
that
we're going to hear some hope about the
direction of america and the future of
america building toward a more perfect
union
that is something that we have heard
throughout our history in this country
and and so he's going to speak directly
to them he's going to make the case he's
going to be optimistic he's going to lay
a path forward
and um and that's what matters and
that's why it's not he's not going to
focus on a political party he's not
going to focus on a political person
he's going to focus at what is what
matters what is currently mattering in
this moment and as it is at the heart of
who we are as a country talk about who
we are as a country and um and that's
what you're going to hear from the
president
hold up i just want to try again on oil
price caps uh the russian deputy prime
minister said today that russia will not
export oil to the world market if the
price is capped below the cost of
production so given those comments it's
not entirely hypothetical given he said
that is the white house concerned that
russia would refuse to sell oil under
the cap which would then cut off supply
and potentially raise prices prices
again the meeting is happening tomorrow
i'm going to let the g7 uh finance
ministers meeting occur and we'll get
back to you on that but just want to
just lay out what we've done already the
strong actions that we have taken to ban
russian oil and u.s allies have have
announced plans to wind down their own
imports of russian oil we've heard them
make those those announcement
and you know but putin has continued to
try to find new markets for russian oil
so this is the most effective way we
believe to hit hard
at putin's revenue and doing so will
result in not only a drop in putin's oil
revenue but also global energy prices so
we're going to continue to
continue to have our conversations with
the g7 leaders this is what's going to
happen tomorrow with the foreign uh the
finance ministers and we'll have more to
share
i'm gonna go to the back because people
have been saying i'm back on television
phil and then i'll come around
it's good that's great um
returning to our discussion yesterday
following up on some of the things that
you said today i just want to clarify
does the president believe that the
effort to restrict abortion
to restrict that freedom
is semi-fascism
say that how is this connected to
yesterday i'm just trying to think so in
terms of uh extremism the extremism
conversation that we were having
yesterday does the president believe
that the effort to restrict abortion
whether it's at the local level or the
federal level to restrict that freedom
does he believe that that is semifinal i
mean he was very clear he was very clear
that
mega republicans in congress have
an agenda that is extreme and that's
what you hear from them of the national
ban
on abortion is extreme and also it's not
in line with where a majority of
americans are it is just not it is
taking away people's rights it is taking
away people's freedoms uh and you know
he doesn't he believes that is an
extreme agenda you've heard that from
him directly i don't even need to
confirm that from here he's actually
talked about how extreme it is when we
saw what what was done with the dobbs
decision on june 24th
to take away
a right that people had for 50 years a
constitutional right for 50 years that
women had to make a decision for
themselves
on their health care
and
and so yeah we see that as extreme so
but i'm trying to figure out which
bucket in particular to put it in
because the administration as well as
the president has used a different
language here there's extremism and then
there's also the semi-fascism
moniker that he used i mean this is an
effort that's been around for a long
time does he believe that this movement
working through whether it's the state
legislature or congress
is
in either of those buckets when we talk
about
semi-fascism
and you talk about the attack on our
democracy
that's what we're talking about right an
attack on our democracy
that's what we're seeing attacking our
uh on our freedoms that's what we're
seeing
from the mega republicans in congress
that is what they're doing that is when
you're talking about inciting violence
that's that's that is an attack on our
democracy
and when you're when you see a mob
that is attacking the capital
and you don't call that out or you call
it out one day and then change your mind
the other day another day
what is what message are you saying
about our democracy
but specifically with regards to
limiting these freedoms i guess my
question is the supreme court created
this space
for
the
anti-abortion movement at the state
level and also perhaps at the federal
level to try and restrict this freedom
where do they fit into all of this how
would the president describe them after
that decision were they just extremist
or were they you know part and parcel of
a semi-fascist look here's what i'll say
we can continue to see attacks on
people's fundamental rights right um of
americans with new abortion laws across
the country
and when you have
national republicans uh who are who are
leaders uh in their in their political
party who sit in office uh who say that
they want to take away the rights uh
even in case of incest and case in in
and and not in case of uh
of rape
and taking away
a woman's right to make a decision on
her body that's extreme
and
and
you know the president's going to call
that out he's going to continue to do
everything that he can to make sure that
we protect people's freedoms
he's going to do everything that he can
to call that out
and
you know that is important to call out
that is important to talk about
and again we see majority of americans
who disagree
and so when you are not with where
majority of americans are
then you know
that is extreme that is an extreme way
of thinking
i'm not gonna that's what i have for you
phil
i just laid out what he's gonna talk
about it's not a political part it's not
about a political person it's not about
a political party
it's about where we are currently today
and
[Music]
where we are currently today with our
democracy thank you
thanks great has the administration seen
a spike in the request for covet free at
home test since the deadline is tomorrow
has there been an increase this week so
excited yeah there has been a
significant increase this week in demand
uh since uh we announced the suspension
as you know which is happening tomorrow
of thecovettest.gov
because of a lack of funding from
congress and as we prepare ahead of the
winter we had to make some tough
decisions look millions of orders have
been placed
this is a testament of how strong the
demand of a popular program
has been americans want ready access to
test to protect themselves and others
with more funding we'd expeditiously
resume the program that's what we're
hoping to do uh and we're going to
continue uh to work with congress on
getting that funded everybody who
requested them this week will be able to
get before we're going to do everything
that we can to make sure that
we get people there their tests and one
more code question uh with uh the new
boosters likely
rolling out next week after the fda gave
the eua
yesterday
with pharmacies now being told to retire
the old boosters and now going forward
only the new boosters will be given out
what happens to all of those old
boosters can they be
reused repurposed can they be donated to
other countries or will they be just
wasted at this point so that's something
that i uh i can't speak from here that's
going to be something that the fda will
clearly give some guidance on
thank you uh
go back to tonight's speech obviously
you said that the president's gonna be
calling out these lawmakers that are
maga lawmakers in congress
but you had 74 million people vote for
trump last time around you said it's a
small number that the white house
believes are extremists can you give us
an idea of ballpark are we talking a
million of that 74 million are we
talking about one percent 20 percent
what kind of number
well i'm talking about um
i'm talking about specifically of uh
maga office holders that's what we're
talking about they're the ones
i'm talking specific i already answered
this question uh about how um you know
we feel like we've touched a nerve right
when when folks are are are saying uh
that we're we're trying to be divisive
or that we're talking about millions of
voters that's not what we're talking
about here we're talking about mega
office holders uh who who
who have put forth an agenda that is
extreme who have put forth an agenda
that takes away uh people's rights who
have put forth a agenda that uh you know
want to give tax cuts to billionaires
and corporations while raising taxes on
million americans uh we just had a back
and forth about uh how they want to do a
national ban they've called for a
national ban on abortion those are
extreme
that's an extreme agenda that is not in
line where majority of americans are i
know you're asking me about uh 10
millions of voters out there but we're
talking about if you look at the items
that i just listed majority of americans
don't support what the mega republicans
in congress are doing that's a fact
that's what polling shows us when you're
talking about an agenda
from republicans in the senate who are
talking about getting rid of uh medicare
putting that on the chopping block
putting social security on the chopping
block that's not popular that's not
something that majority of americans
want
so if it's mega office holders we've
seen democratic groups something like
the democratic governors association
boost trump candidates like maryland if
you think of dan cox who just got the
nomination
is that then hypocritical if you're
saying we've got to make sure these maga
supporters are not in office but you've
got democratic groups that are boosting
their campaigns in the primaries i mean
i can't talk about campaigns and what
another another candidate is doing or a
committee is doing i can't speak from
that
from here
look i can say this the president has
been has always been clear uh there are
going to be people who disagree uh with
his programs and legislative priorities
and that's what democracy is all about
like we understand that right but people
accept elections and we move forward as
a nation right but there is a growing
number of people who refuse to
accept the results of free and fair
elections people who actually openly
talking about subverting elections in
the future this is not a speech where
he's going to tell people to vote for
one party or the other that's not what
he's going to do
he's going to i'm talking about tonight
i'm talking about tonight he's going to
talk about uniting the people of this
country who believe in equality and
democracy and this is about bringing
people together who believe in america
that's what the speech is going to be
about and that's what he's going to
focus on and obviously there's been a
lot of focus on previous speeches
previous comments one in maryland the
other day
is it only on the far right that
deserves to be called out or are there
elements of the far left that also
deserve to be either scrutinized or
election look i'm i just laid out there
is going to be some people who agree
with him and who disagree with him uh
who agree who
whether it's legislative
initiatives or programs that's going to
happen
but what we're going to hear from him is
how to move the country forward that's
going to be the focus of the speech
tonight he's going to be it's going to
be optimistic it's going to be hopeful
and it's but it's also going to lay out
what's going on currently in this moment
that's what you can expect from him uh
tonight and uh and
you know we're going to try and see how
we can move this country forward last
one for me is you know he's going back
to pennsylvania tonight he's going on
monday for labor day he's doing
wisconsin you know everybody here has
been asking about mississippi no plans
to go see what's going on on the ground
uh i just said the fema administrator
i just i just said the fema
administrator is going there tomorrow
that's going to be important she is she
is the administrator of fema one of the
most important uh uh
agencies as we're as we're dealing with
the with this catastrophe that we see in
jackson that is not unusual
that is not new for her to be the first
one on the ground to to make sure to get
a sense of what's happening and what is
going on where you know we have the epa
uh epa who's also involved the epa
agency was also involved as well the
president is going to continue to have
conversations with local governments the
local elected officials in in the state
and uh and our team is going to continue
to do that i just don't have anything
else to preview but it is not unusual
right to have the fema
i'm not saying that i just said i don't
have anything to preview but it's not
unusual for her to go down there as
you've seen with other uh where we have
other catastrophes sadly across the
country uh and fema takes takes action
and then it take the lead
speech please yes thank you um so you
mentioned autopsy democracies will be
part of the theme that the president
will touch on today does that mean that
he's returning to
um kind of foreign policy theme that
he's
often highlighted in the beginning of
his administration will there be a
foreign policy component in the speech
and he will he mention specific
countries
i'm i'm not going to get ahead of the
president i just laid out it's going to
be an optimistic speech it's going to be
about
how where our country is currently and
fighting for our democracy how we're
going to
move forward
and
and also how americans can also
participate in making sure that we
protect what's important uh to us as a
country
there's going to be autopsies yeah
he'll he'll i said he'll talk about that
but you're asking me specific things i'm
just not going to get ahead of the
president i just laid out what he
believes he wants to to talk about
tonight what he believes this moment is
all is all about remember we're going to
do this at independence hall which is a
historic uh which is a historic place to
do this speech
so this is an important moment doing it
in prime time making sure that he
connects with the american people and
again this is something that we believe
majority of americans care about
and so you'll hear from the president
tonight another follow-up on afghanistan
from my colleagues
i understand the focus now is on the sid
program but just to follow up on a more
brief note i think earlier this month i
believe august 5th you
said that the withdrawal anniversary is
an opportunity to honor the lives that
we lost and recognize the lives that we
save and how we are on a stronger
strategic footing now that we've
ended the war
and so it seemed at that time that the
administration was at least i mean to me
and correct me if i'm wrong planning to
mark the event in a way that would
highlight those issues that you
mentioned at that time but instead we
have this narrow statement from the
president not on the withdrawal itself
but on the anniversary of the kabul
airport attack so can you explain the
thinking behind the that messaging
strategy and could you please respond to
the criticism that the administration's
goal here is to downplay the withdrawal
anniversary and kind of just put it in a
rear-view mirror so i'll say a few
things we remain committed to supporting
the afghan people
and we are proud to be the largest
single provider
just to remind you all of humanitarian
assistance to afghanistan we are working
closely with the united nations and
other partners to provide the assistance
directly to the afghan people without
benefit to the taliban
we will remain vigilant against any
terrorist threats as we demonstrated in
july
when we took down or took out the
the leader of al-qaeda
we will continue to prioritize
relocation effort for our afghan allies
and welcome our afghan allies to the
united states since our commitment to
them is enduring and we will continue to
press
the taliban for the safe release of mark
ferrix and to respect the human rights
and fundamental freedoms of all afghans
including women and girls that is our
goal that is our commitment that has
been
our commitment
for more than a year now and uh and uh
again we are committed to supporting the
afghan people and we will do everything
that we can in what i just listed i'm
going to keep going i'm going to keep
i'm going to keep going
i'm going to keep going go ahead yeah
thanks green so you read at the top of
this about the president's uh
statement on manufacturing and
announcement of those new jobs when will
those jobs materialize and when the
government subsidies go away like the
chips act and american rescue plan will
those jobs also go away
so um look
the reason that we announced these uh
what we announced what uh macron is
doing for solar toyota honda and corning
if you think about macron they're going
to a 15 billion dollar investment over
the next 10 years
that is going to create a lot of jobs
and that's going to be in idaho look
they're going to i'm sure they'll share
more on what that process is going to
look like but the point that we're
making is because of the work that we've
done the chips act let's remember that
was actually a bipartisan piece of
legislation the fact that we were able
to come together to work on this
important manufacturing bill right
that's going to help
make sure that we create semiconductors
here that's what this uh but what that's
what this manufacturing facility is
going to be about making sure that we
strengthen our supply chain making sure
that we strengthen our national security
making sure that we're doing the made in
america
that is an important
step forward and so they'll provide more
information but certainly 15 billion
dollars that they're say that they're
going to invest and create their first
manufacturing to deal with
semiconductors that's an important step
forward and that's because of the work
that this administration done and that's
why we highlighted it
so i want to ask you about campaign
promises well candidate biden said they
would end the fossil fuels industry then
he went back and said that he's not
going to end all fossil fuels
we've seen increased regulations and
restrictions uh in that industry
pennsylvania is the third largest coal
producer in the united states in the
past year we've only seen about 1600
jobs
in net added to mining and lodging in
that state so why not just change the
energy policies help out pennsylvania
with jobs and
energy security look
we just passed the
inflation reduction act which is going
to
which is going to do what's going to
change people's lives and is the most uh
which is the most historic investment
that we'll see
uh that we have seen in this country uh
to deal with climate change right to
deal with um to deal with energy and so
that is important there and let's not
forget the bipartisan infrastructure
infrastructure law as well that's going
to deal with climate change and so look
we're going to continue to do the work
this is a commitment that the president
has
he's created as you know you've heard me
say this almost 10 million jobs new jobs
since he's gotten into office uh the
bipartisan interest infrastructure law
infrastructure law is going to create
jobs where you're not going to need a
college degree that's important 90 of
those jobs you won't need a college
degree
that's going to be important to
pennsylvania that's going to be
important to many communities across the
country and he's going to do this in a
way that he's me he's he's going to meet
his campaign promises and so when it
comes to
the climate the climate change and
fighting climate change when it comes to
making sure that recreating jobs when it
comes to building up
the uh the economy from the bottom up
and the middle out that's what he's
committed and that's what you see from
all of the pieces of legislation that
has come out of this legislation when it
deals with the economy
okay all right i'll be back tomorrow
guys thank you thanks everybody
you